Екстремісти, які все плюндрубють та підпалюють - це ще не весь Гамбург.
Після ночі погромів тисячі людей вийшли на вулиці міста,
щоб продемонструвати незгоду із насильством.
"Організатори хаосу, посоромтеся!",
- написано на цьому плакаті
Кольорові кульки та музика.
Одним словом - мирний протест проти насильницького
Саме таким має запам’ятатися місто,
яке приймало саміт Великої двадцятки,
вважають його жителі.
Дуже шкода, що весь час показують,
що тут самі розбої і Гамбург у вогні.
Адже те, що я тут бачу і протягом трьох днів співпереживаю,
це дуже піднесений настрій.
Я за те, щоб G20 працювала і люди між собою розмовляли.
І без насильства, щоб досягти кращих цілей.
Поліція, яка вже дві ночі поспіль вгамовує екстремістів,
знала про цю загрозу.
Учасники погромів півтора року готувалися до цього, заявили в МВС.
Саме тому в поліції чітко проводять межу
між десятками тисяч мирних демонстрантів
із численних політичних та аполітичних таборів, .
і злочинцями
Характерно, що хоч злочинці і маскувалися під учасників мирних демонстрацій,
які виступають проти G20.
від їхніх безчинств постраждали не політики.
Люди в масках не намагалися завадити, наприклад, рухові кортежів.
атомість підпалювали та плюндрували звичайні вулиці.
На це звернула увагу й господарка саміту.
Насильницькі демонстрації загрожують життю людей,
ці люди ставлять у небезпечне становище самих себе,
поліцейських, служби безпеки, жителів міста,
і тому це нейприйнятно.
Тут жителі Гамбурга із канцлеркою згодні.
І незалежно від того, хто з яким прапором чи транспарантом вийшов на вулицю,
їх об"єднала ідея мирного протесту.